que supone para la posición
internacional de Colombia y para la
propia figura de Petro esta reunión con
biden
la posición del presidente Gustavo Petro
porque tiene una agenda marcada en
términos de lucha contra las drogas
apunta al otro tema de la paz cambio
climático y un tema que es el tema de
migración y relacionamiento con
Venezuela creo que es clave en la medida
que la gente detectó Busca ser la
bisagra de Estados Unidos y Venezuela
porque eso además que puedan mejorar el
relacionamiento también Colombia podrá
incluir tanto a Venezuela en dentro de
la mesa de negociación con el eln porque
estas organizaciones se encuentran este
territorio pero también lograr de
convencer a Estados Unidos de presentar
un representante de su país en la mesa
también de negociación con para lograr
la paz total con el Elena entonces creo
que los temas son cruciales para no
solamente Colombia sino también para
Venezuela y Estados Unidos bueno es que
se está hablando mucho de Esta visita en
relación a la conferencia internacional
sobre Venezuela precisamente organizada
por Petro la semana que viene en Bogotá
que representaría el compromiso de biden
de levantar sanciones a Caracas a cambio
de elecciones Bueno eso es un punto que
está en juego en la mesa de México que
fue que se congeló quiero que el tema de
eliminar las sanciones ya venía desde
hace meses entre Estados Unidos y
Venezuela lo que sí genera algo de temor
es que ya hay unos puntos avanzados en
México y que no sabemos Cuál va a ser la
postura actual ahora del presidente
Petro y cómo se enmarcaría esta nueva
Cumbre con los ya acordado en México y
creo que eso es una tarea bastante
difícil y que Creo yo que aquí a los
tres actores o cuatro actores con la
oposición tienen que sentarse a crear
unos mínimos pero sin lugar a dudas creo
que es clave y que creo que lo que pasa
en Venezuela tendrá una proyección
también con Venezuela con Venezuela y la
paz total en Colombia y en cuanto a la
protección ambiental tema clave de la
política no solo de Petro sino también
de Lula da Silva en Brasil biden se ha
comprometido a donar 500 millones de
dólares para el fondo de la amazonía de
Brasil se está posicionando biden del
lado de esta Nueva Ola progresista en
América Latina o es una mera postura
táctica Creo yo que son las dos cosas al
mismo tiempo una cosa no excluye a la
otra creo que además el movimiento y el
contexto político internacional da para
que Estados Unidos se incline ahora
hacia estos temas medioambientales pero
sí quiero Rodrigo que este tema y la y
el tema de la del medio ambiente con
Brasil Colombia Estados Unidos puede
generar ciertas rivalidades o cierta
incomodidad con los con el vecino país
pues no hay que olvidar que el
presidente Petro en enero de este año
mencionaba que ya había avanzado unos
diálogos con Estados Unidos para
ingresar a la amazonía colombiana
algunos elementos miembros de la otan
así como también que recibió por
donación los Black Ops de Estados Unidos
no sé hasta qué punto esto le vaya a
gustar a Lula Silva que él digamos que
tiene ciertas diferencias en esos
aspectos territoriales con América con
Estados Unidos en América Latina así
como también su acercamiento de Lula con
china en las en la semana recientes eso
es un punto que es clave yo creo que
Estados Unidos le apuesta de cambio
climático porque entiende que en América
Latina y países que tiene la amazonía
tienen un una mina importante para todo
este tema de la transición energética
Pero hay otro factor que es importante y
que creo yo también Estados Unidos va
atrás también No solamente la amazonía
sino también tácticamente de La Isla
gorgona la cual en Colombia pues ha
habido ciertas manifestaciones y que le
ha tocado restringir algunas decisiones
del gobierno colombiano que había
autorizado la construcción de una base
militar en la isla de gorgona por parte
de Estados Unidos entonces creo que es
táctica Pero también es un elemento
progresista porque es un tema que está
en la agenda política y que una no
excluya la otra y que por el contrario
Estados Unidos también le convendría eh
incluirse en esta nueva política de
cambio climático y más con estos aliados
de América Latina que tienen el
potencial en esta transición energética
para el futuro